What do we got here? Oh,
Oh, wow. Dude. Whoa.
First of all.
Kenny, Chris, crystal, Leah. This is by John Lindros at true underscore baby 97.
Cool. Crisp accuracy. What do you think of the name of Kenny?
Chesney's new tour. Okay.
Those of you that don't know what it is.
I'll tell you right now. It's called
chillax suffocation.
Uh.
Dude, now let me tell you something.
Tour 2020, starring Kenny Chesney course, chillax, suffocation, Florida,
Georgia line course and old dominion and Michael Franti and spearhead.
Dude. Let's just break that down.
Chillax suffocation. Now
of our frog shake, man.
If I hear somebody say chillax,
Quite a lunch, I'm out. I don't deal with you
in a respectful way anymore. Unless you're like a housewife.
Cause then I get it. You're not hip to what's hip,
but if you're just like a dude and you say like, yeah,
the bros are coming over to chillax a little bit.
Uh, you know, we're just going to chill ax.
[inaudible] all right. Okay.
I don't do the two words that are added into one word. I don't do the ginormous,
bro. That makes me want to move it. Fantabulous. See ya.
Um, so chillax. No. Okay.
If occasion, okay. That's another two words.
That's actually maybe three words together. It's California occasion
cation.
So that's like vacation if chillax,
SIF for vacation. So is,
there's actually three letters in there that don't even need it really to make
it, to make me stop here in Bacon's
chillax sick cation would make me hear less bacons. Right?
But [inaudible], it's, that's
like saying like, you know, doing the thing where it's like, when people think that it's funny to say breast
diseases
still, even though David Alan Grier made that funny and 1943. And then it was funny for about 10 years because David, Alan Grier did it.
So
stop doing it now. But chillax suffocation is then forwards together, but they all multiply each other. So let's put it this way. It's not forwards. It's four times four or some. So
that's 16% of how many 16 times how many beckons I'm hearing promoted by sponsor
blue chair Bay, which I don't even know what it is. Dude. Kenny Chesney, for real, this is something I know bought an Island. How he
must
, first of all, he must be so rich. Let's look at his net worth right here. Even though this is so wrong, you
could
look up any celebrities, net worth, and it's mostly wrong, but it's still something I go by
because the internet said it net worth net worth
190 million. And he's probably my age. Right?
Who is the richest country singer in the world? Toby Keith 500 million. Yep.
Dude, bro.
500 million for singing about your dog.
You know what I mean? Dolly Parton 400 Shania Twain, 350 million.
Honestly, that doesn't impress me much. George Strait,
300 million Kenny Rogers,
250 million Taylor Swift. Well, okay. 200 million Garth Brooks, 150,
50 million Johnny Cash.
120 million while I know there's a problem there because he's not spending any
of it right now. Um, Garth Brooks. Wow.
Garth Brooks is not the
Toby Keith and I don't even know if Toby Keith walked through the door.
I would straight up be like, Hey man, can I help you? I wouldn't know who he is.
Toby Keith let's look him up
until the Keith Morrison. Toby Keith bro.
Let's look him up $500 million. Yeah. If this guy walked through the door,
wouldn't know he was wow.
He looks severely different in all of these Google images.
Whoa, is this guy shapeshifter I mean,
God, this guy's wide. Huh?
He literally is so white. It looks like
somebody would be like, yeah, my friend's a black guy. And he would be like a,
what? Maybe like a black guy. And he goes like this, sorry, I don't follow.
Maybe be like, what do you mean? You're like, what are you talking about?
He says, Oh my buddy's a black guy. And he would be like, yeah, no,
I know what you're saying, but I can't what you're saying. What do you mean?
He was like, we know he's like, uh, he's like African-American descent.
Like he's uh, he says, and then Toby, Keith would say what?
And he'd say, I'm sorry. I don't know what you don't get. He says, well,
what are you saying? You're saying, he says, well,
you know how you're white and Toby Keith would be like, wow. Yeah, you,
God right. I'm white. And he'd be like, Whoa, dude, chill. Yeah, no,
I understand. And I'm white as well. And he was like, of course you are.
And then he'd be like, okay, well my friend is not white. And then Toby,
Keith looks like he would, when, when,
after that point that Toby kids would laugh for four straight minutes.
And then he would be like, ah,
wiping tears away from his cowboy eyes and just be like.
Oh, ah.
And then he would say like, well, what is, what is he?
And he says, this was saying he's black. And he's like, like a black,
like he's the color. He was like, well, he's kind of brownish actually.
You know, it'd be like, so he's a Brown guy. And he'd be like, no. And he said,
have you ever seen somebody not white?
And until we give them left for six more minutes and, and cry, laughing,
and then focus our way.
Yeah. What are you talking about, man?
And then he would just put a star being like
[inaudible] my dog and my house. They only get him to deal with it.
Then with him playing the radio dude.
Country songs, love singing about playing the radio. It's unreal.
How many countries songs are live.
Radio on skip it, bro. You're like a chick eating sushi,
talking about sushi. See ya. You're boring.
They'll talk about the thing you're doing. Talking about some elsewhere.
You're doing the thing this way.
You cover more ground and you can have a personality, every country singer.
Just like we turned the radio on sitting back. Yeah,
top down. And we're rolling through the freeway. 91.
Don't just name freeways And the breeze fields.
I don't give a how the breeze feels. The breeze feels how the.
Breeze fields.
Clouds coming, Brown brick and Brown, Brown, Brown, Brown, Brown, bro.
I'd much rather listen to something like
[inaudible] it's runny crews, Brown
[inaudible] Oh.
That is the compared to that. They don't even know when they're getting,
when they're getting a note to Alexa for vacation is what we're doing.
A Marlin getting my private jet.
And it's sponsored by blue chair Bay and Florida,
Georgia line going to be there.
And there will literally be nobody in this concert fan
or artists. That's not wearing a tank top
and shorts with cargo pants on.
Even though shot to never have cargo pants.
I never have cargo pockets because are shorts and.
Pants. I don't need a package.
Cause they only need it's like what do you want fabric?
And not don't just take the fabric off the shins and then put more fabric
above your knee. They create a pocket.
[Inaudible]
if Toby Keith walked into a for real Popeye's chicken, he would be like.
What's going on, man? What the?
What is going on?
Oh my God. Are you kidding me?
Are these faithful
dude?
Oh. My thing went.
Out. Who are these people? That's good.
Oh man.
He can walk into a what's the Boulevard,
Alvarado Boulevard. And just see a whole bunch of Mexicans.
And Toby kid would drive through his driveway drive through and he'd be like.
Man, pull over for a second. Roll down these windows.
Oh, Whoa. Look at this man. You see that thing next to that?
Frilly donkey. But that's hanging right there. The pinata, sir.
What is the pin? Jada? The pin.
I'm talking about the frilly donkey. They're the colorful one.
Are those people smacking? That thing
kids? No. I mean, what is the color of them?
We're late. Let's go.
If Toby Keith stepped in.
To a Glendale Galleria, he would be like.
[Inaudible] is going, Oh man,
I'm sorry, man.
Let me just get on that. I came here to fix my phone and this kiosk.
But what are you? Sorry, a person. Right?
Okay. Like a regular person.
What color are you?
And what is the chain man? And the,
what is I with all that? Where you're from? Where? To
where in America is that?
Hey bro. It's not in America, man. Hey, first of all, stand back bro.
I get a lot of this guy, man. [inaudible].
Hey bro. Don't come in my face like that, bro. You're.
Yelling at me right now, man. And the tip of your cowboy.
Hat is hitting my eyebrows.
Browse man. Whew.
That was a thicker. My buying Rawls, man.
I gotta get outta here man. Hey y'all are too much, man. Y'all.
Too much.
Where are you? Not eight. Everybody loves everyone. You want to get a.
And then Nunu.
I saw a Brown guy and another Brown kid and then a Brown guy.
They want to get to a. They were doing, they were in wow.
They want to get anyone.
Even though they were another color and they were new and I didn't go near and
my white friend, they showed me that they were still people.
Now when they get here, and then they went down there and now, now I said, Whoa,
Aria, are you a real person down there? Nailing it. Gonna go in there now, now,
now, now, but it's not my fault. Cause I'm so bad. I'm grand solution,
Liam. Didn't do a deal. No knew. I got up here to cars
and my cowboy hat goes down in the front. But up on the sides down,
they get them. When they're down there now.
I have.
Hundred million. [inaudible] never seen someone,
not 10 during the day when they're new and they're new.
And they haven't seen someone who was darker than a tan whack out there and to
get even to get to go. No, no, no. I don't even get tan. I get
paying I'm the color of balls. Don't get even nicknamed there don't know dough.
I'm the color of under a Turkey's beak.
They don't have nicotine and nicotine when they're doing them though.
Don't know, dude.
So dude, Toby Keith, hasn't worked out a day, dude.
He just chills, man. He wears pants.
30% Of the time, dude, he doesn't give a.
He's literally taking rides in a car and got out of
his house with no pants on God in the car.
No pants drove to Starbucks, had somebody to get out, get in the car.
Starbucks went back to his house. All with no pants on duties for sure.
Done at doing he's for sure. Done it. Holy, dude.
Ah, God it.
I never seen a guy be so good looking and also so not good-looking it's
unreal. This guy's great. He's great. He's great.
He's the Mickey Rourke of country singer Mickey Rourke is like the handsomest
most. And also it looks like, Oh rock.